i'm delighted to be able to show you
this paper this is as you can see called
toggling bistable atoms via mechanical
switching of bond angle and it's the
result really of 18 months worth maybe
even more than that of experiments and
brady filmed some of those experiments
um maybe six or seven months ago we had
to keep the results of those experiments
we had to keep that video really secret
until now
and now that i've got the page proofs in
my hand we can go ahead and show you
that that work
so what we see are each individual blob
here is a single silicon atom these
atoms form little pairs called dimers
which are our little two atom units
we're going to bring a tip in and we're
going to move one of those atoms change
the bond angle and flip it so what we
basically have is the smallest possible
toggle switch you can have this is this
is all happening in here in an ultra
high vacuum system the pressure in there
is 3 by 10 to the minus 11 millibar 14
orders of magnitude below atmospheric
pressure
and
roughly and at a temperature of 4.7 k so
it's it's happening actually in
in here the atom that was once here the
atom that was down what we've done is
we've brought the tip and we've pulled
that up so it's
jumped up underneath the tip and
suddenly appears at this this this new
position why is this impressive it's
impressive because we are not only
manipulating individual atoms
and
measuring the force required to do so
it's impressive well i think it's
impressive in that what we've basically
got is we're
pushing on the smallest possible switch
you can have so
the very first time this experiment
worked the very first time we actually
flipped an atom happened at oh
23 in the morning on
[Applause]
the 13th of january so quite some time
ago so we've been doing this experiment
and adam in particular has been spending
a lot of time in the lab at nights and
mornings so what you're looking at is
the first time it actually worked um
where this we saw this change and this
change we were expecting so lots and
lots of attempts nothing happening
nothing happening going all the way back
some things happening here not quite
what we wanted but all the way back lots
and lots of experiments lots and lots of
time trying to do this to work and then
suddenly it worked
and so yes flipped and an expletive this
tip that you use to flip the switch to
move individual atoms tell me about how
big that is so that tip is right at the
end we want it terminated with a single
atom and in fact we spent a lot of our
experiments trying to get the tip to
that point
in fact the majority of our time is not
doing the really exciting interesting
stuff like this the majority of our time
majority of adam's time in particular is
getting the tip into a state where we've
got one single atom sticking at the end
but what that tip is is basically a
piece of tungsten wire bog standard
tungsten wire that is etched
electrochemically etched down to a fine
point and then it's attached it's
literally glued onto a tuning fork a
tuning fork actually from a quartz
synthetic tuning fork that's in a quartz
watch in every quartz watch and every
quartz clock there's a there's a tuning
fork that basically vibrates back and
forth and that's the timing element so
with these experiments what we do is we
glue the tip to a tuning fork and the
way we can work out the force between
the tip and the sample is to look at the
frequency of that tuning fork basically
to look at the frequency of one of the
the legs of that tuning fork and how
that changes i do we spend
very very many hours it goes through
fits and starts sometimes
it's it's almost never quite nine to
five but sometimes it's almost nine to
five but then other times like last
night adam was in here until us we
actually
worked
we worked until nine o'clock we went out
for a male adam came back at 11 o'clock
and worked through until six in the
morning and sometimes we do we pull 24
36 hour shifts so we're looking again at
those rows of silicon atoms
um so here's one row here's another row
we're basically changing the the
orientation of these dimers um along
this row by using the tip to influence
each
each dimer so we are flipping individual
atomic switches basically it takes about
a half an hour per scan um so what we
have here here's our first image of the
surface
where what we've what you really want to
focus on is this atom so that atom is
the up atom or one of these little
switches so we've got an atom here we've
got an up atom which we can see but then
over here we've got a down atom we've
got the lower atom which we can't see
and then what we've done is we bring
brought the tip in above this atom and
we've pulled it up and then what happens
is it looks like that so now we can see
the up atom and the down atom's done
that so we've got a flip we've got a
toggle
we've toggled this switch between those
two states and we're
on a single atom single chemical bond
basis
you